[Musica]
[Applauso]
è una croce e una croce e non si deve
dire che è un crocifisso è proprio una
croce nel senso che non c'è il
crocefisso
anche perché c'è l'imbarazzo
di chi ci deve stare su questa croce
certo quello più famoso quello che ha
dato un senso anche a questa croce che è
detta una best come bestemmia come
offesa come tortura e sicuramente gesù
cristo il cristo e tutti gli altri
poveri cristi
veramente c'è un
elenco interminabile nella storia
scusatemi però giusto per capirci e di
che cosa stiamo parlando
uno di quelli che è salito su questa
croce due giorni fa e un bambino di 12
anni si chiamava sala
abitavano il signor che il kurdistan
iracheno e i turchi che stanno mediando
la pace tra russi e ucraini li stanno
bombardando
bombardando hanno fatto un morto di 12
anni sala un altro che cup che è salito
su questa croce qualche giorno fa
davvero pochi giorni fa e si chiama
mohamed mahmood
aziz
veniva dal darfur
rivedo al darfur 19 anni da dove c'è la
guerra dove c'è la violazione dei
diritti umani su ampia scala
e
mohamed
fuggiva da quella situazione che
riteneva assolutamente
insopportabile ma come tutti i
i migranti che arrivano da quell'area
vengono poi portati
condotti segregati nei lager libici che
noi italiani e che noi come unione
europea
abbiamo finanziato insieme alle milizie
che li sa che li catturano questi che
hanno la sola colpa di desiderare di
vivere
questi che chiedono bussando le nostre
porte delle nostre città opulente
semplicemente pane e dignità
e c'è un'ipocrisia di fondo per cui
questi li respingiamo li fermiamo nei
lager della
della libia e può succedere come a
mohamed che
sia più duro che il darfur per cui si è
impiccato si è tolto la vita è salito su
questa su questa croce
c'è un razzismo strisciante
un'ipocrisia collettiva una schizofrenia
incomprensibile per certi versi perché i
profughi ucraini trovano assistenza
integrazione e quegli altri che hanno il
colore forse della pelle diverso
non hanno questa questa possibilità che
cosa ci sta succedendo
che cosa ci sta succedendo questo è il e
il tema no non riusciamo a riconoscere
più il desiderio degli altri che
risponde ad un bisogno a una necessità e
un bisogno primario quello della vita
quello della vita
e allora in questo senso penso che
diventi utile e importante
comprendere come
si
qualche anno fa ho trascorso qualche
anno in carcere non come detenuto ma
come cappellano almeno questo
c'era un 1 di il nostro direttore del
carcere di questo carcere di massima
sicurezza
ad alto indice di pericolosità diceva i
nostri ospiti
però i tutti i nostri utenti
questo carcerato aveva fatto più anni di
carcere che non di vita libera e
e come tutti tutti i detenuti hanno una
produzione aveva anche lui una
produzione onirica molto forte ecco il
desiderio il sogno che veniva in tutti i
modi soffocato soprattutto negli affetti
nelle relazioni appunto per una persona
che rispetta in una in una cella e e lui
aveva però questo si era fatto un suo
percorso per cui aveva che era riuscito
in qualche modo a trasformare la la
cella della detenzione in una sorta di
cella monastica e aveva trovato questa
questa capacità rappresentativa molto
forte che lo aiutava a vivere e appunto
in cui i sogni diventavano poi quadri e
affinato una capacità anche pittorica
piuttosto forte è un giorno mi ha detto
stanotte ti ho sognato dico non avere il
piglio di meglio da sogno e non era
sognato in questa maniera nudo si vede
male forse però è nudo che mi trascinavo
dietro una nave che ha un significato
storico la nave di nelson e la nave
della sconfitta no è però quella
sconfitta
viene trascinata e nel suo trascinarsi
lascia un solco e perché se è vero che
il desiderio e il sogno danno ampio
spazio poi alla sconfitta
alla delusione alla paura di non
riuscire poi a compiere a realizzare
tutto questo non è mai tempo perso il
desiderio non è mai tempo perso il sogno
perché in ogni caso traccia una strada
una strada che all 3 possono possono
possono percorrere dopo di te ma ancora
più interessante che in questo sogno e
lui arrivato visto gesù cristo in questo
abito bianco quasi trasparente che si
scaldava ad un fuoco alimentato dalla
croce stessa la croce diventava veniva
sconfitta e diventava calore per chi ne
aveva ne aveva in qualche modo bisogno
allora da questo in questo senso in
questo punto da questo punto di vista mi
sembra che il sogno il desiderio sia
assolutamente vicino
parente come dire vicino di casa del
parente stretto del camminare non ci può
essere sogno e desiderio senza cammino e
mi viene in mente il
l'immagine di un poeta uno scrittore
della dell'america latina eduardo
galeano il quale a un certo punto dice
eh sì e sì perché è l'utopia è l'utopia
stalli all orizzonte io cammino di
cinque passi per raggiungerla e lei per
di cinque passi si allontana allora
continuo a camminare a percorrere la
strada faccio altri dieci passi e
l'utopia si allontana di dieci passi
allora che cosa serve andare verso
l'utopia se non riuscirò mai a
raggiungerla auto kia
forse serve proprio a questo a camminare
e allora il primo il primo suggerimento
consiglio quasi scaldando c
vicendevolmente i muscoli e proprio
quello di non smettere di camminare
sogniamo sognate desideriamo ma
camminiamo e camminiamo verso l'utopia
io quella che ho che ho visto che ho
sognato finora è quella della della pace
che diventa utile bella importante
una pace che don tonino bello diceva più
che un vocabolo e un vocabolario perché
poi ciascuno sono convinto che avvenga
così anche per noi e se io dicessi che
cosa intendiamo per pace ciascuno di noi
ne avrà un'accezione diversa
un'inclinazione i terroristi
sono terroristi usano la violenza si
lasciano andare ad ogni tipo di violenza
per la pace la russia aggredisce
l'ucraina perché vuole la pace perché
cerca la pace la pace no e allora
dovremmo essere davvero molto cauti
molto attenti e e riuscire in qualche
modo a darci delle delle coordinate per
seguire una rotta che si essenziale una
pace sganciata dalla giustizia che pace
una pace che non non si costruisca ad
esempio concretamente nella nonviolenza
che pace e quindi diventa essenziale
importante questa non semplice rinuncia
della violenza non una presa di distanza
dalla dalla violenza ma qualcosa di
molto più importante di molto più
profondo
e quello che gandhi chiamava
chiamava satyagraha che era la forza
della verità ed era un'intuizione
profonda e bella che dovremmo forse
riscoprire riproporci continuamente
perché se due persone si contendono un
bene e molto probabilmente arriveranno
ad azzuffarsi a litigare per stabilire
alla fine chi dei due è più forte
il più abile il più furbo
adotta le strategie migliori non chi dei
due ha ragione
e allora nella guerra non vince nessuno
[Musica]
non è una partita di calcio e semmai un
con vincere un vincere insieme
è un vincere insieme allora se non
violenza ha un senso ha un senso
all'interno della fraternità e
attenzione non lo dico perchè son prete
la fraternità non è soltanto un valore
scolpito forte nel nel vangelo è
altrettanto ben definito nelle nelle
costituzioni
occidentali perché è uno dei tre
principi forse la cenerentola di quei
principi della rivoluzione francese
e allora capite che se il mio fratello
non sta bene se mio fratello
viene minacciato dalla violenza dalla
guerra io non posso rimanere
indifferente
e allora oggi pensare appunto al
kurdistan iracheno pensare al darfur
pensare alla siria allo yemen ad haiti
alla alla colombia pensare alla siria
capite che
pensare all'ucraina
anche se a noi purtroppo sembra quasi
che ci sia una sola guerra e perché lì
ce ne sono
826 di giornalisti accreditati in questo
momento mentre dall'altra parte non c'è
conoscenza non c'è informazione non
siamo siamo all'oscuro di tutti allora
se mio fratello non sta bene io non mi
do pace
non mi do pace
e allora mi muovo mi commuovo
e allora vivo con lui il sogno della
pace che non è più quello che dicevamo
una un una cosa intima personale e non è
avere una la pace del cuore che già
sarebbe importante ma non è soltanto
quella diventa piuttosto un cammino e
guardate che è davvero
strano e paradossale ma il luogo in cui
la parola pace e scritta ed è più citata
è quella dei cimiteri su tutte le lapidi
no e noi siamo più abituati a dire che
pace in questo luogo
là dove appunto non veniamo disturbati
da nessuno piuttosto quindi a siamo
legati ad un concetto statico della pace
non al cammino che abbiamo visto
all'inizio la nonviolenza si mette in
cammino la nonviolenza mi fa vivere la
fraternità con l'altro e allora giovedì
prossimo noi ripartiamo con stop the
wall now questa coalizione di 176
organizzazioni nazionali e locali per
per per l'ucraina e ripartiamo
attenzione portando aiuti umanitari ma
non solo quelli facendo anche stando
vicino alla gente cercando un po di
condividere insieme con loro quella
condizione perché se porte soltanto gli
aiuti umanitari
sembra quasi che
fai la stessa cosa che faresti se ci
fosse stato lì un terremoto uno tsunami
un un fenomeno naturale una sciagura
naturale una tragedia naturale
e quindi paragoni la la guerra ad un
fatto assolutamente
ineluttabile al quale bisogna
assoggettarsi
rassegnarsi e non è così non è così e
noi vorremmo essere forza di
interposizione metterci tra gli eserciti
che si stanno confrontando sul terreno e
non ne abbiamo la capacità non ci siamo
abilitati e quello che dovremmo creare e
quello che dovremmo cominciare a fare no
ma tutti
tutti allora andiamo almeno a dire a
quella gente il mondo non vi ha
dimenticati e vogliamo condividere con
voi la stessa precarietà la stessa
fatica almeno per qualche ora almeno per
qualche per qualche giorno stop the war
now punto è un vi prego e spero davvero
che qualcun altro si aggiunga alla
carovana o perlomeno aderite in qualche
modo partecipate diventa essenziale
altrimenti c'è davvero una disumanità
da questo punto in questo in questo
senso c'è una disumanità
perché dobbiamo essere capaci di
rimettere al centro l'uomo
ecco vedete io penso che gesù cristo non
sia venuto a fondare a creare a proporre
l'ennesima religione ce n'erano già
tante e poi adesso sono ancora di più
rispetto all'epoca sua io penso che il
compito la missione di gesù sia stata
quella di del cristo non è l'insieme
poveri cristi la missione del cristo era
quella di rivelare l'uomo a se stesso di
metterci di fronte alla nostra stessa
nudità e
ed essere capaci in qualche modo di
viverla fino in fondo
tutto questo ma guardate a volte mi
succede scherzo con gli amici mangiando
una bistecca dico che sono vegetariano
l'evidenza e dicono un attimo sono
vegetariano non praticante
e questa categoria del non praticante si
applica soltanto alla fede alla
religione non solo
e quindi non ha senso dire solo
cristiano non praticante non solo ma il
cristiano non praticante significa che
non frequenta il culto la devozione e
gesù invece ci ha dato ben altri
parametri che è appunto il mettersi al
servizio di un progetto per la
costruzione di un mondo nuovo allora che
delusione scusatemi una chiesa che sia
preoccupata piuttosto delle persone che
si amano che hanno un senso diverso che
abbiano lo stesso sesso ma che comunque
ci provano ad amarsi a volersi bene
piuttosto che
preoccuparsi molto di più delle mafie e
delle guerre e della violenza
allora vi chiedo davvero
aiutiamoci tutti quanti aiutiamo anche
questa chiesa questa comunità cristiana
ad andare avanti a creare un mondo
milione che migliore che sappia mettere
al centro al centro la persona umana e
vi chiedo di essere praticanti in
umanità
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]